So, when did homework become the never-ending nightly nightmare we know it as today?
It was in the 1950s that things started to change,...
...and homework finally reared its ugly head.
At the time, the US was competing with the Soviet Union...
...and tried to get any competitive edge they could find.
One of the ways they wanted to get the upper hand was by raising smarter kids.
Teachers and school districts were encouraged to assign more homework...
...so that American students would outcompete their Soviet counterparts...
...and grow up to be scientists and engineers,...
...and by the 1950s, less families needed their kids to stay at home and work the fields.
So, there wasn't a huge outcry from parents once the assignments started rolling in.